[Música]
Guerrero una semana después de la
victoria de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
en las urnas simpatizante del presidente
saliente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
continúan con las manifestaciones en las
principales ciudades del país
estoy aquí hoy porque quiero la libertad
de Brasil No aceptamos el comunismo
los simpatizantes del presidente extrema
derecha se rehúsan a aceptar a la
izquierda y ya dos veces presidente Lula
Quien ganó las elecciones del pasado 30
de octubre con un estrecho margen de los
votos válidos algunos de los
manifestantes bolsonaristas llevan
varios días ocupando las calles y
protestando frente a cuarteles generales
del ejército de Brasil para pedir una
intervención militar
luego Aquí cuatro días y no me rendiré
nuestro Brasil necesita ayuda
pero el entusiasmo bolsonarista parece
menguar ya no se encuentran activos la
gran mayoría de los bloqueos de Los
camioneros por las rutas del país por su
parte manifestantes a favor de Lula
también salieron a las calles y
organizaron una fiesta para exorcizar a
Brasil de bolsonaro
es el Día de exorcizar a evolucionar o
exorcizar a la derecha acabar con los
prejuicios acabar con la xenofobia y la
homofobia ya es suficiente
es el Renacimiento de Brasil nos estamos
convirtiendo en Brasil otra vez el
presidente Jair bolsonaro no ha aceptado
explícitamente La derrota pero prometió
que respetara la constitución en un
breve pronunciamiento lo que redujo los
temores de una transición de poder